hey you guys look it's a bonus movie
retrospective for this week just like we
promised
we're finally doing old boy because this
is the one that won
in the patreon poll but if you've been
watching any of our live streams or like
read our patreon messages or anything
like that
um we had a little trouble getting hold
of this movie
all of a sudden when i put it in the
poll initially
like when i put it in the pool of movies
that we were going to do it was on
shutter along with the other two movies
in the it's
the loose trilogy um you know sympathy
for mr vengeance and lady vengeance
so all of them were on shutter but then
when this movie won the poll
um you know uh it was gone and uh i
couldn't find it
it wasn't on amazon prime it wasn't on
anything so
finally i just had to order the dvd off
of ebay and we finally got it so we're
finally getting this up i'm glad we're
finally getting this up on the actual
day that it's actually supposed to go up
even though we put we did an extra one
because i you know figured that it
wasn't gonna
get up in time but yeah so just as we
promised the patrons that voted for this
we're doing the 2003
south korean neo noir classic known as
old boy
yeah we got it on dvd and actually the
dvd quality is really good
it looks like blu-ray it looks very nice
they must have remastered it
i guess but it doesn't look like 2003 it
looks like a new movie
yeah you really wouldn't know i mean
it's really really i mean the visuals in
this are so gorgeous and there's really
there's a little bit of cgi
but not much i think there's only like
one or two very minor scenes that are
cgi'd and you wouldn't really notice
unless you were looking real close
when you watch this movie i can really
see where um
john wick got a lot of stuff there's a
lot of john wickish
type sets and action in a certain way
not guns but just martial arts
yeah you know fighting with knives and
stuff well and one of the most famous
scenes in this is that like hallway
sequence where
you know he's fighting all those dudes
and that was done in one take
the visual tone kind of looks like john
wick to me
yeah it does a bit and like i said yeah
i wasn't able to like really place it i
guess
you know in the day that this came out
but
you know maybe it's just because john
wick is supposed to be kind of like a
kung fu movie
yeah you know and i think it's maybe
that's where old boy gets that look
korean version of a kung fu movie or
something
yeah this is technically like i said
it's usually called a neo noir
it's kind of like i guess it's sort of
like a revenge thriller
but it's a little bit different than
your standard revenge thriller
you know what i mean it's a lot more the
story is a lot more intricate
and um i called it i called it a kung fu
movie it's not a kung mu
not at all more like it more like a a
hong kong
gangster movie that's more what it's
like sort of yeah that's what it kind of
feels like or you know the visual tone
to it that seems like they borrowed it
from that
it also they've kind of um this was
actually directed by uh park chan wook
and so this is actually been compared to
to like a greek tragedy yeah like
oedipus
yeah um which if you kind of follow the
story of oedipus and you follow this
story you will totally totally see
where all this so so it was for sure
deliberate yeah
it's a good movie there's at times i
thought it got a little bit convoluted
in the storytelling
and it kind of lost me um like i lost
track what was going on i was like jenny
what the hell is happening here
you know because it's it's just just the
way it's edited
but it is a great movie you know what i
mean uh nor without jenny i'd probably
have to watch it two or three times to
get every aspect of it i think
i think this is definitely a movie that
um you need to watch a few times
not only because i mean yeah the story's
kind of complicated
but um also because there's a lot of
as i said symbolism there's a lot of
like [ __ ] going back to
you know a greek tragedy type of thing
so there's a lot of that playing into it
like everything in this
is deliberate like the color choices
everything
there's kind of flashbacks and flash
forwards sometimes it'll lose you
you're like hold on where am i you know
yeah you really i mean this is one you
really got to pay attention gotta really
pay attention to it uh but yeah so like
i said this came out in 2003
um the second movie in as i said it's
sort of a loose trilogy they don't
really have a lot to do with each other
uh the first one i think was sympathy
for mr vengeance
and then the third one is lady vengeance
neither of those i've seen
i don't they might still be on shutter i
don't know they added all three of these
on shutter at the same time and i
didn't see them and now they're
apparently gone uh so this was actually
based on a
manga now let's talk a little bit about
the snow now we
probably this came out in 2003 and if
you haven't seen it like i said it's a
[ __ ] classic [ __ ] south korea man
they just like
they're so good at these type of [ __ ]
movies
yeah well horror movies action movies
revenge thrillers like i said i mean
this one
if you loved um you know i saw the devil
which is one of the best movies i've
ever seen ever which is also south
korean
it's like you really really need to see
this one as well because this is
there's a caveat to what she just said i
lived in south korea
in their very early 90s you know for
about a year
no during the time i was there 1991
korea made crap
it was [ __ ] all right it was what
happened at a certain time
evidently there were guys my age in
korea thinking the god damn the same
thing they're like man we gotta really
we need to make some good yeah
for a change what was traditionally
happening
in korea is it was kind of like
knockoffs of what was popular
cheap knock-offs of what was popular in
the united states or japan
there wasn't a lot of original stuff but
then i noticed you know around
late 90s early 2000s all of a sudden
korea started swinging for the fence and
a lot of good stuff was coming out of
there yeah
original stuff a lot of like action
movies horror movies and stuff like that
that started coming out of south korea
around that time period
like 90 of them now of course you know
you know all your filmmakers are
influenced by good films from all around
the world so you do see influences in
from japan and hong kong and america but
that's fine
they didn't try to directly rip off
what the hell was going on sometimes
they would just kind of
get into a trend and put their own take
on it you know that's kind of like
this is i think it's kind of like a john
woo flick actually
yeah you know i think it's a korean take
on something that maybe john
but a lot better writing you know they
too was it wasn't it wasn't a cash grab
good original storytelling this one is
much more focused on there are fight
scenes in it and like some kung fu if
you want to call it that but like you
know
some kind of down and dirty fight scenes
um and there is some
violence um some of it quite yucky
or you know squirm inducing but it's not
the
the kind of point of the movie isn't
that like it doesn't
shy away from that kind of [ __ ] but the
point of the movie i think is more
the you know the this intricate story
this intricate plot that plays out
um and also kind of i guess in a larger
thematic sense
almost like the fact that you can't
control your fate or there are always
like
you know forces larger than yourself
that are controlling even though
it seems like you have free will which
we might get into when we talk about
because like i said this came out in
2003 so we're gonna spoil it um because
there are some kind of
there is kind of like a real big
revelation at the end which
are you gonna look for that too which
it's better if you don't know that
going into it i don't know if i spoil
that i shouldn't
no because man it's so hard to talk
about without spoiling that though
because yeah this movie's been around
for a long time but
not everybody's seen it it's kind of a
rare movie and man it's really really
hard to get hold of like i said i
couldn't get a blu-ray
yeah i had the dv the dvd i got was used
it's in gorgeous condition it looks
fantastic it's expensive too it was 20
bucks like for a used dvd but i couldn't
get it and like some of the other copies
were like a hundred and forty dollars
you know like that i've heard that if
you have a vpn which i finally broke
down and got nordvpn today because i'm
just like man [ __ ] it
um i think maybe you can watch this on
south korean netflix because that's one
of the things you can do on a vpn you
can watch netflix from other if you have
a
you know a uh account you can watch
other countries
i don't know if it's on there still but
i watched another review of it and they
said that it was on korean south korean
netflix
so that's where they watched it so i
don't know if it's still there but if
you have a vpn like check it out and say
it used to be on shutter but it's gone
now i need to get off into the vpn
action i just got it um i just did it i
did uh because
you know dan bell that hits one of his
sponsors so i used his
uh thing and so i got it it was 89
for two years vpn and cryptocurrency you
can make all kinds of illicit purchases
well i don't i don't care about why i
don't even care about a list of
purchases i just want to watch some
netflix and hulu from [ __ ]
they don't want you watching that that's
funny well it's like i don't care
you think they'd want me to watch their
[ __ ] movies it's like if you want me
to watch you don't put it on our
shutter or our netflix it's like so i'm
going to go around
that's [ __ ] american corporations all
these corporations are [ __ ]
corporations are [ __ ] well that's not
[ __ ] isn't that what the guy in hong
kong said yeah
yeah i mean it's just that they're
sociopathic in the sense that all they
care about is making money
so you know what i mean yeah and well
yeah kinda
okay go ahead yeah um so i will say
before we get too much into the plot if
okay so maybe if you don't want me to
spoil it maybe i won't spoil it but i
will kind of go into what the plot is
this film also won the grand prix at
2004 uh the cannes film festival and
quentin tarantino
big fan uh which should come as a shock
to
zero people because so he because i
think he was like the president of
whatever like the um you know that
decided like which movies were gonna get
the [ __ ] that year
and he was just like he loved this movie
so much so
alright so this movie follows a dude
named odaisu now when you first
i'm sure i'm pronouncing everyone's name
wrong so i'm so if you're a korean i'm
terribly terribly sorry you know i don't
really mean
i can't pronounce anyone's name so yeah
so odaisu
is kind of this middle-aged dude and
he's introduced at the beginning
um apparently he was on his way home for
his daughter's fourth birthday party
but he got a little waylaid uh at a bar
and uh he got completely and utterly
shit-faced
and it's implied that he got into a fist
fight with some people so he's like you
know causing some trouble so he's in a
police station
for presumably drunken disorderly he's
in a drunk tank yeah
and he's just not happy he is just
acting
up that's what koreans do when they get
up
firsthand
on the ground rolling around trying to
throw bricks at people and stuff you
know what i mean hit the cops sitting
there watching them and trying to
keep them contained and they got a lot
of tolerance for trucks though in good
korea
at least they when i was there you could
probably drive drunk and get away with
it
well they're just like oh people
drinking you know [ __ ] happens
he's had too much to drink you know that
that's you know
cute look at him trying this a lot to do
for law enforcement in
south korea just saying they don't have
a big crime problem
well yeah i mean well that's nice
you don't have a big cry problem but
yeah so
so he's like trying to pee in the corner
why not so the cops are just kind of
like oh geez here we go
now so he has his friend um juwan and
his friend comes
and picks him up now they go to now this
this part of it this prologue i guess is
set in 1988.
so uh juwan goes to
a phone booth like right outside the
police station
and uh they call um odysseus's wife and
it's just like you know he got way late
at the bar it's like sorry about that we
we're bringing him right now because
it's his daughter's birthday party or
whatever
but then when juwan turns around
mysteriously
oh daisu has disappeared and all that's
left is this bag that has these little
angel wings that he was going to give to
his daughter for her birthday so he's
gone
so you find out a little bit later that
odaisu has been
kidnapped by someone and put into
what is essentially a private prison
yeah it's a private prison kind of run
by gangsters
it looks like a hotel room like a pretty
okay like hotel room
yeah and so they lock him in there
they feed him like under there's this
little like
hatch in the bottom of the door and they
push tray and they give him he has a tv
he has a bed he has like it's not a
prison cell it just looks like a hotel
room yeah they pretty much only feed
them something called yakimandu
yeah which is in in in korea it's kind
of like their version of damn hamburger
it's like quick to go food you'd know
them here as potstickers pot stickers
or uh in chinese probably call them like
dumplings yeah they're like fried
dumplings yeah they're pork
ground pork watching this movie really
made me want some yeah
he was getting sick of them because that
was all they were that was all they gave
him for like
so so yeah so and what they do is that
at night i don't know if it's every
night
but whenever they need to do something
in the room or do some kind of like um
maintenance on him or whatever they'll
gas him and put him to sleep
and then they'll come in and cut his
hair and clean up his room and all this
other kind of stuff yeah his room
doesn't have a window it's got a fake
window of a [ __ ] dutch windmill
yeah and it's got a nighttime phase and
that's all he's got to look at and
television and he's going insane he's
basically in solitary besides that's
television
yeah so he's in there and he finds out
from the tv
that his wife has been murdered and he's
been framed for the crime so like the
gangsters that are keeping him
they're keeping other people too it's
like a whole complex
um and they have come in like after they
gassed him and they took a glass that he
had drunk from and they used like the
dna or
you know or whatever the fingerprints or
whatever to like frame him for his
wife's murder so even if he gets out
he can't go anywhere he can't go
anywhere because he's a fugitive from
the law they think that he
you know killed his wife so he ends up
being in there
for 15 years and he has no idea
why he is in there um he has no idea who
put him in there
you find out later on that this is
essentially like a private prison where
you can pay a gangster it's like hey i
don't like this [ __ ]
here's all this money and like lock him
up but they don't tell you why
yeah so they won't tell you who did it
and they don't help tell you who did it
so basically so he's in there for 15
years right and he's
gone a little um a little loopy yeah he
was pretty good
he was training though he's punching the
walls getting his knuckles real hard and
doing physical exercises
trying to escape and he did eventually
escape well he tries to
well he starts to escape it takes him a
while like he he's doing like a [ __ ]
shawshank redemption where he's like
trying to get around this brick with
like with a chopstick
and it takes him a while metal chopstick
yeah yeah now
just when it seems that he's going to be
able to escape like he's kind of busted
out
uh one of the bricks or whatever uh they
knock him out with the gas and then when
he wakes up there is a woman in there
who seems to be hypnotizing him
now after that he is
released they pretty much chuck him out
of the prison onto the roof of a
building
he's in a suitcase and he pops out of
this suitcase
in a new suit and all this other stuff
and there's this guy there who's
wants to jump off the trying to commit
suicide he's trying to commit suicide
dog in his hand well see i didn't get i
didn't pick this up
but i was watching like another
breakdown of it and apparently i don't
know
if the guy was going to kill himself
because him and the dog were in love
and like he was [ __ ] the dog i guess
he couldn't that's i didn't pick up on
that but i saw another review that said
that
right so i don't know if it was
mentioned and it's like i don't you know
what i mean
so he was a bestialist yeah because i
think that the person
who had done the review could also speak
korean okay yeah
so i think that that's what why that
dude was killing himself because no one
because no one would um accept his
forbidden love
for this little dog yeah it's like holy
crap yeah it's a poodle
yeah or i think it was it was it a a
bichon or
it was something like that media curly
haired dog is a food that's a little
yappy type yeah
yeah so basically he's like okay well
you can't die because i have to tell you
this crazy [ __ ] story of this [ __ ]
that i just went through
so average so the time that he that um
odaisu has been
in this prison and he started like
training he was in there for like six or
seven years i think before he even
figured out hey i'm gonna start training
so when i get out i can like
revenge myself on whoever the [ __ ] did
this to me because he has no idea why
uh so after he gets out he starts like
you know beating up people
starts to go into like an investigation
of who and why he was imprisoned
now during the course of this
investigation very early on one of the
first things that he does is he goes
into this sushi place and he meets this
young
sushi chef named mido
and in probably one of the most infamous
scenes in this movie certainly the one
that made the largest impression on me
he goes into this place and he says to
mito i want to eat something that's
alive
yeah unexpected inexplicably didn't
really know why he wanted to eat
something that was a lie
she'd bring some damn octopus and he's
eating a live octopus that's fighting
him and
grabbing his nose oh my god it's hard it
is real
yeah and he had to do that like four
times damn
that's um yeah kind of like
that's a commitment to a role kind of
sad to see some people have theorized
that a damn octopus might be about as
intelligent as a cat
but that's what i was thinking the whole
time i was i found it very very yeah
but in but in in nature they're eating a
live by
by fish anyway i mean that happens
anyway sure
yeah but you know i'm just i'm just
saying if you don't want to see a dude
eat a live octopus like for real
maybe like fast forward over that part
but so uh so what ends up happening
is that him and mido kind of like fall
in love because i guess
he after he eats the octopus he kind of
like
passes out and so she kind of takes a
shine to him even though he's much older
than her and
uh you know takes him to her house where
he uh
almost immediately tries to rape her but
then he's just kind of like oh sorry
because she's like hey get off the
get off me like with a knife or whatever
yeah he's doing all kinds of weird [ __ ]
because he's been solitary for 15 years
one of the things that he does when he
gets out immediately gets in the damn
gang fight over cigarette
yeah because he just pulls it out of
dude's mouth and then he starts biting
his ass he doesn't care
yeah he's like oh he's enjoying it well
i think if he hasn't had any stimulus
well and he wanted to test out he was
because when he was training in his room
yeah he's like i was just beating up
like the wall or like watching tv or
whatever so i wanted to see if it would
work in real life yeah so he just like
picks a fight with these like four or
five
teenage kids there was more than that
was there more than yeah i can't
remember
six to eight of them but it was like a
gang yeah and so he just he beat that
ass
yeah but one thing that was kind of you
know
living in korea is one of the things
that was accurate is that the the dudes
you know they
they're not big they got you know little
bitty arms and uh
this guy after he comes out of that damn
prison he's in relatively real good
shape
so yeah yeah i've seen him use taekwondo
on each other
they were drunk you know what i mean and
it's just
[ __ ] pitiful and just slap fight and
then fall apart and they recompose
themselves and get back into a taekwondo
stance and slap fight
[ __ ] funny man they're not
koreans are not fighters in that way for
the most part unless they're like
golden bat [ __ ] unit which is one of
their special forces units right next to
our unit they were badasses
but looking back on it those dudes were
riding they were on a juice
they were big they had to have been on
the juice
yeah it had been legal to get in korea
it all comes back to testosterone it all
comes back to [ __ ] testosterone and
[ __ ]
anabolic performance is [ __ ] big yeah
bigger than any other career you saw
walking around they were like
bodybuilders
yeah yeah yeah so all right so
um as i said his kind of quest for
vengeance
uh leads him and medo and his friend
joo hwan who in the interim in the 15
years
after he disappeared um he was the guy
from the original
part that rescued him from the drunk
tank he has kind of established this
internet cafe
type thing so he's kind of like a
computer packer computer program or
something like that
so the three of them start doing an
investigation to find out what exactly
uh where he was held why he was held who
was holding him there
and uh interestingly i love the way that
he finds out is because like i said the
he was eating those fried dumplings
that's what they gave him like every
single day for like 15 years
and he figured that they were getting it
from a restaurant nearby
so hint the first thing that he does is
him and mito
go to every single restaurant in the
area that has fried dumplings
and he eats every single one of them
like to see which restaurant they got it
from and then when he finally finds out
he follows the delivery man like back to
the building
so he eventually does find out
who it was that put him in this prison
but it takes a long time before you
figure out
why and that's the thing if i
say why they put him in there
it's gonna ruin it yeah actually finding
out why it happened is really
one of the best parts of this movie yeah
it totally kind of encouraged
jane not to spoil it and then how the
revenge
actually plays out
you know what i mean that that's
actually kind of like
it's pretty [ __ ] up yes i mean not not
in the sense that because like i said
there is a lot of violence in this like
i said you see a dude eat a live octopus
a lot of people's like teeth get
pulled out yeah a lot of like teeth
torture that kind of funny though is
that there's this kind that kind of
stuff in the movie but the tone is kind
of like a john wick tone
yeah so it's not repulsive in the way
you would think it is
it's almost kind of humorous in a way
kind of it the tone is just right
it has like i feel like it had a lot of
dark humor
yeah like it had a real dark humor kind
of vibe to it
when you pull a dude's tooth out it's
not totally
you know what i mean turning you off to
where oh [ __ ] it i gotta turn this
it's not like that you're just like you
just you accept it you're like okay
yeah and it's not super super graphic
it's not real graphic
um i think it's just a lot of it is kind
of more your suggestion about
like the sound that it makes like
because you're just like
you know what i mean because it makes it
look like it's bad watching all this
stuff happen so too especially in the
very end that's kind of like oh
but you don't have to see it it's just
suggested
that it happens a lot of the time yeah
and sometimes this sometimes
the suggestion is kind of worse and then
you're like
okay here's something that you have a
lot some people have to understand you
know if they don't know korea real well
korea is not a buddhist or confucianist
type nation it's christian
so the morality of the movie
is being is playing off of christian
values
so the taboos that are happening in this
movie
are the taboos that you're [ __ ]
seeing in other words
yeah what what is happening is not
acceptable
in korea you know what i mean it's it's
the same moral system so that translates
very well
it plays like i said no yeah what's
happening
in this movie as it unfolds you can't go
oh well maybe that's acceptable in that
culture
no it's not no no well it it being
unacceptable
is kind of the main kind of fulcrum
behind
everything that happens grands are
presbyterian i think
but that's the thing well like i said
this plays out very much like a greek
tragedy
you know what i mean it's very very
similar to you know like oedipus the
king or something like that
um and if then there's a lot of
references to that story yeah
in this um which i don't know if that
spoils it or not but
so the interesting thing too is that
even though
like i said usually when people talk
about what genre it is it's usually
a neo-noir is what they say it's not
like an action movie necessarily even
though it has action set pieces in it
um and it also it kind of gets called a
revenge thriller too although the
interesting thing about it
is that the person getting revenge
isn't necessarily the person that you
think it is
i guess if i can put it like that
there's red herrings and stuff
yeah and as i said this is one of those
the the plot behind it and when and as
the story unravels and he starts getting
closer and closer to
what exactly is going on why he was
imprisoned and who did it and for what
reason
um this is one of those movies that you
really really have to see several times
because there's a lot
of details in there that um
that you might not pick up on the first
time that
uh really come into play like the more
you see it like i said if
there's even like all kind of symbolism
about uh the patterns of the wallpaper
in the back and like you know the
uses of uh the color red the uses of the
color purple
like all these different kind of um you
know symbolism and things like that that
they're using
that is not super apparent the first
time you see it but
the more times you see it like it
becomes like a lot clearer like the kind
of the grand theme of it like i said
i feel like the the theme of this
thematically or you know
the overarching theme of it is kind of
like
you not having any despite you thinking
that you have control
over your actions there's always like a
force greater than yourself that's
actually controlling it so it's almost
kind of like a fate
type of thing but in this sense
so as i said it's very much like a greek
tragedy it plays out almost exactly like
that
but um yeah it's just this i i just love
this movie so much i think i saw it back
when somebody came out of 2003 i don't
think i saw it in the theater but i
think i saw it a year or two after that
i either rented it or somebody loaned it
to me and i remember really really
liking it i
only remembered i remembered a few
things about it i remembered like the
live octopus eating because man you're
never gonna forget that when you see it
believe me i remembered that and i
remembered
the big revelation at the end although i
only remembered it
halfway through the movie when we were
watching the movie last night and i was
just like oh
i just remembered like what and it's
like i think that i remember unless i'm
thinking of a different
movie but i'm like i'm pretty sure i
just remembered like what the big
revelation was yeah uh at the end and
yeah i was right about that so i did
remember that but other than that i had
forgotten a lot of it so it was really
nice to like see it again
now the dvd version that we had came in
multiple languages we first
when it first started it came in in um
which it looked no money
and kind of low budget so we flipped it
over to
original korean dialogue with
subtitles and it really makes the movie
a lot more upscale
i mean you're like oh okay yeah english
dubbing just always makes movies seem
cheap yeah i don't know what it is on
the downside
on the downside of the subtitles is that
um
the story reading the story it
seemed especially when you got down
towards the middle part of it and beyond
it started to seem kind of
overly complex and um
convoluted but they're doing that on
purpose
because they're trying to kind of like
conceal
the big reveals towards the end and it
all kind of comes together
and but if you don't know if you know
that going in it's probably a lot better
i didn't know that going into the story
so i kept thinking i had missed
something yeah like
hold on how do we get here you know
right what happened
you know so i'm doing the old man thing
huh what did you say what's this around
what's the old man thing i started doing
the old man thing who's this now
yeah you tell me you tell me that you
don't do that but you totally do
what's going on what's going on wait is
that is he really out or what's what
he ate the chicken no what was the one
that was the goat
the goat he ate the goat he ate the goat
it was jurassic park that's why i still
remember
the old man that was 1993. i saw
jurassic park with my friend in the
theater
and there was a really old dude sitting
next to us and he just kept commenting
on him
who's this why is he at the door what's
going on who's that on the phone
it ate the goat yeah yeah
at that point i like cracked up but then
i turned around i was like thank you sir
thank you he said that yeah and his wife
was just like
yeah he obviously was uh he was losing
it
sounded like he was a little bit of
alzheimer's and deaf
too probably because he was talking like
in a normal yeah
tone of voice well some people go to the
movies
as a look at me opportunity don't look
at the movie look at me
look at me reacting to the movie yeah
like [ __ ] this isn't mystery science
theater yeah
they're funny you know what i mean
but yeah so um also too i kind of want
like i said i feel bad that i can't
spoil it because there's so much i want
to talk about about the ending and i
really really like
the ambiguity of the ending um
it's it's just a really really
interesting ending and i'm just curious
so if anybody has seen this and you know
what happens in it
then just put it down in the comments
and we can talk about it down in the
comments just put like spoiler in the
like put some faces and [ __ ] like that
because i do kind of feel like even
though this has been out for a really
long time
like you said it is it seems kind of
difficult to get hold of yeah
um you know it's like jeremiah johnson
one of the best movies ever made
very few people in the modern era have
seen it yeah i want to do a show on that
too
amelia's flick yeah we should actually
yeah it's a it's
one of the best movies ever made and not
many people have seen it
yeah i've seen youtube reviews of it and
they only got a couple hundred
views a lot of comments but it's like
it's four or five guys commenting yeah
yeah we love this movie yeah somebody's
talking about it yeah it's a robert
redford movie
you know that's one of the best movies
ever made shot on location and
you know and it was just some things
just fall between the cracks yeah it's
like you never really know and a lot of
times it doesn't have to
do with how you know uh how good the
movie is like sometimes
it's just the timing wasn't right or
maybe it just didn't appeal to a wide
enough audience or something it wasn't
always like
it did well at the time i did well at
the time in the 70s it just kind of got
forgotten
it got forgotten yeah you know it didn't
it didn't
it's a long movie that's kind of slow
that not a lot of dialogue but it's
beautiful and scenic and epic
it's like conan but it's happening in
the damn mountains and mountain men
and [ __ ] and a one-man war against the
crow indians who tried to kill you're
trying to kill each other over a woman
it's it's
it's a good story wow
you know based on an american legend
jeremiah [ __ ] johnson
also known as liver eating childhoods he
was cannibal yeah all right which
they kind of leave that out but in real
life you
he was a dude that got who who gone
injured is what it was called he went
india yeah he's eating people's livers
to [ __ ] get strength
as you do as you do well
i don't know i don't know so he did it
he was like a crow
well it's like you know just just in
case it could be true yeah
so it's like you know just covering all
the bases like you do
uh but yeah so as i said um you know i
feel bad that i can't spoil it but
i really do kind of feel like especially
nowadays because it seems like it's
kind of hard to get hold of as i said
it's really not available on any
streaming services in the us at least as
of this recording it was on shutter for
a little while but it's gone now
i think there's a couple of sites i
think there was a site called asian
movies online
like with dashes in between i think
maybe you can watch it on there for free
um that was maybe like a i think the app
was called b flicks or something like
that we couldn't get the app on ours
that's why we didn't end up watching it
on there
but um you know so maybe you can find it
somewhere nobody's put it on youtube as
far as i know
at least in a decent you know thing but
so i had to buy a used dvd off of uh
you know off of ebay but check
the south korean netflix see if it's on
there or something like that because i
definitely feel like this is
if you like asian cinema at all you
really do need to see this movie because
it's like a [ __ ] classic
um and you'll really dig it i promise
yeah it's it's really entertaining i
mean it's yeah
in a weird kind of way also it's like a
really nice looking movie too i really
like the
yeah you know the dvd looks really great
but yeah so that will do it for our
finally at last review of old boy
and we will see you guys on the next one
bye